okay for people who are joining this
live stream this is our weekly meeting
about language completeness and
consistency and we haven't been having
too many of these live streams as I
mentioned in some previous ones partly
because we're in the finishing process
for version 12.1 and partly because I am
working very intensely on my physics
project which hopefully will be ready to
livestream and tell people about quite
soon few weeks alright let's get into
this one okay so first of all we're
talking about icon eyes I can eyes out
put for the size limiter oh that's cool
alright so it's in the prototype build I
hope I have the prototype build why
don't have an icon for the prototype
built six seven double zero one three
eight or well I'll try this one six
seven yeah that should definitely be
recent enough okay can somebody flag the
fact that I don't have my usual icon for
desktop the prototype build that Roger
no yeah right so this is sort of really
just a rough prototype and just one at
you know sort of solicit feedback and
you know Billy from design is here so we
can talk about anything that lets go
bigger okay what am I looking for
right so under store there's I I think
we already lost the game we've got tons
of screen real estate here we really
need them the UM
[Music]
yeah I I don't see why we shouldn't just
you know show what we want to show here
rather than hiding it under these rather
obscure categories right well then I
think the show one makes sense right
because it's right that's the old menu
that lets you show more or less all I
don't know why that isn't okay okay okay
let's talk about this for a second okay
okay show less is fine but not relevant
until you are showing more correct it
okay I mean I really don't like this
the current okay so first of all the
fact that it says large output you don't
say I mean what what what does it say in
master I is that something has always
said large output it has always been the
label okay I guess well let you know
that you're not seeing the whole thing
right so I guess we I guess it's been so
long we've just sort of tuned that out
of our heads until now where we're
taking a fresh look at it right so to me
the explicitness of these buttons I
really like I don't I particularly like
the buttons but um I mean the settings I
agree we could hide that although it
seems rather silly to have a pulldown
that has one thing underneath it Angry
although we could imagine an auto I can
eyes setting I don't know whether we
want that setting I mean okay um okay
let's see what this actually does
okay so store as I can heist
not behavior it's just bizarre to me I
mean what do you mean store I mean as in
okay so why can't I say show I can eyes
I'm totally confess 'old yeah because
what's there what's in the notebook now
is not the complete expression what's in
there is a reference to out and you know
a partial right the whole point of this
thing is that we are not typesetting the
entire expression okay so other things
that have a story notebook like data set
and so on how does that work or like
audio if I say you know audio capture
okay hello there
okay does why doesn't that have a store
because that well I I don't know but
right so yeah I think that's a different
I mean you want to look at things like
dataset and sparse array right so if you
did sparse array of that range
you
you
okay this motif is what we have to use
here if this is our motif this is what
we have to use here I'm not completely
sure I understand what you look what I'm
saying is I'm saying this is a
completely different kind of way of
showing stuff okay so first of all look
to me the options are convert to icon
eyes form look what I think we should
say is store in notebook you know as
icon um in current form I don't like
those words but you get what I'm saying
so are we talking about a drop down no
no drop downs no drop downs okay so he
having not a a label that's not a
clickable button which is store in
notebook and then we have two buttons
that are clickable possibly but I don't
really like I would prefer everything to
UCI I think this day's are not a
notebook store now is a useful sentiment
except you know most of the time is pure
output you know you know I'm beginning
to think what we should do is they
convert to icon eyes to convert to
ionized convert to icon
and then we could say data not a
notebook store now same thing be well
except the convert to ionized form is
missing the fact that it's also doing
the store now I'm going to assume that
people implicitly realize that I know I
I think because they don't even know I
didn't even know it takes me real
thought to realize that this isn't in
the note you know okay hold on what what
other things do we need to do so first
of all there's show more
show all
you
and you know at times our show less that
time showed us right um right wait wait
wait such a second sir um store full
expression in notebook I was actually
going to suggest the opposite that we
sort of reversed the order of the data
not a notebook store now have that first
and then store as icon eyes or store in
ionized form I I don't like that because
I think this is much much much the most
useful thing I I can't I don't know when
I would ever use this I'm sorry I think
we are missing mixing two things here
one is the storage the other one is the
coping so in imagine and I hadn't
realized before I thought that this was
not storing the information in the
notebook so you know Jose the fact that
you and I both as longtime users of the
system barely knew that is a sign that
it just doesn't matter yes but now
report about it which we have me now I
realize that they useful theme will be
if in a notebook I click store in the
notebook and then later in a different
session I can come back here and say
copy this as a micronized and put it
somewhere else
because I like the fact that I'm seeing
what is there it says that in the next
section in the next session I want to
copy it back it is certainly the case
that you know the the principle problem
here is that we're trying to do a you
know sort of the two-step things showing
it in one step
I mean one could imagine whether or not
you like it is another story but one
could imagine that you simply have no
option to go straight to ionized form
unless the data are in the notebook you
know so once you store the data then an
icon eyes thing shows up no I hate that
but you're writing their transactions
there's convert like an iced form here
and copy as I can eyes form but leave
this and there's right there's a third
right I mean who's I pointed out that
there's another state people might want
which is store the data but leave it
display it like that so you see the you
know you have exactly that's what I'm
saying so yes store full expression a
notebook leaves it like this just stores
it in the background so let me just say
that I I find it a bit curious that were
kind of you know taking this whole
attitude toward this interface you know
the interface was originally conceived
as basically a way of saying well you
probably did something you didn't intend
to do and here's you know a low
consequence way of visualizing what you
probably didn't intend to do whereas of
course if you did intend to do it you
could have simply added slash slash like
nice yes but you don't think of that and
also sometimes you want to see that no I
I disagree with many premises of that
your claim yeah okay I do this because I
actually want to see roughly what's
coming out right I want to get that
wasn't the original I know this in it
for another purpose I understand that
but you know you know we build things
and then think of how it works and
biological evolution it builds something
and then it gets co-opted for all kinds
of weird purposes you know same thing
here right this is useful well it's so
but the reason I'm bringing this up is
because you know all of its current
design you know came from a particular
point you want another point of view
maybe we should change the point of view
maybe we need to change some of our
assumptions right we've changed the
point of view so let's just
take this from the top okay the idea
that you have a panel that represents
this big output just fine as far as I'm
concerned okay I don't have a problem
with that personally graphically I think
having this be more obvious border at
the bottom would be nice more like this
this kind of thing you know what I'm
saying what where it's where it's kind
of an attached button II thing where
there's the panel here and then there's
an attached button thing underneath
Billy if you if I'm making sense there
yep
and you know the capitalization and so
on I mean this is okay so what what I
think I mean first of all this show more
clearly we need that show all we clearly
need that now if we know how big it is
do we have any idea how big it is or do
we not have any serious idea how big it
is
well we certainly have the byte count
right yeah yeah understanding and we
don't have its full typeset
representation and so there's a certain
amount of knowledge that we're lacking
there and the reason we don't is because
you know that's part of the cost that
we're trying to save is the generation
of that expression so we know it's byte
count we know its underlying byte count
right yeah yes I think it will be useful
to give that I mean it doesn't tell you
how big it is when it's formatted but I
mean it gives some sense if it's you
know if that number was a gigabyte I
would not press show all right I think
that information is in the sparse array
case and a tool tip if you want to see
what we've done for that there you go
okay fine
what do we say in me in the right-click
menu for the I think we could get away
with just saying I can eyes particular
if we put an icon of the icon eyes thing
there that's what I'm proposing and then
the set
could say um always score full
expression and notebook oh I don't think
you actually want that that is ice cream
has been asking is asking for that but
yeah but they even if they're asking for
it I don't think they actually mean it
because that is a great recipe for
crashing your front end so we have two
big abite practical file limit its size
it's the the front ends not going to
behave well with files larger than 2
gigabytes right and for example the
store now button and sparser a goes away
above a certain limit precisely to
prevent the front end from crashing when
you click on well then let's do this
look set size limit is one thing and
then always store full expression up to
a certain size and it's writing that
well I guess if you're just storing the
expression it's probably not super
expensive it's just big I mean super
size limit for display and then we say
something like that
and let's just understand what it will
do so I can eyes does what you have it
doing right now that is it just turns
into an icon let's look at the icon
turns into oops okay so it's just the
generic icon for that thing correct yeah
okay copy as icon eyes that would
actually do the copy right there and put
it on the clipboard right there Mobley
yeah I'm not sure I mean if we're going
to have separate copy as icon eyes and
stop and you know in certain notebook
I'm not sure that the wording should be
different from what you know what we use
elsewhere for what for right instead of
store full expression a notebook why
isn't it let me tell let me tell you why
because I think some of these things
will not be quotes data at all
so I'm saying I think that's confusing
if it's a sparse array I have no trouble
with data not a notebook but if what
came out was a giant who knows what you
know war and peace or something well
maybe that's data to I don't know I mean
you do notebook readin you had guts what
oh and you got the guts of the notebook
yeah um I don't think data is the right
I'm liking this this collection here and
um he's always gonna
that much room for all the text I well
it'll be the width of the notebook right
so if you have a very narrow notebook I
have fixed bugs that you I think
reported Stephen when viewing this on a
phone to make these buttons look better
off on a very narrow I'll have to
they'll have to stack
they'll have to accommodate yeah
you
okay all right Ethan our live stream is
saying when there are lots of large
outputs it will be nice to have an icon
eyes all output actually what that
suggests is an interesting idea I mean
if it is the case I mean you know if we
believe that slow scrolling and things
are sort of here to stay which I'm not
sure it really is but if it is a thing
which says thumbnail my outputs you know
or bitmap my outputs but leave the data
in there is that a thing genres does
that not make any sense well um I mean I
mean it depends on why things are slow
if things are slow because it's loading
data from disk then you know it's having
the I mean the data in the notebook it's
still gonna be loaded from disk the you
know I mean you know if in that case the
cost was just the amount of time it took
the PAR stuff from disk there are other
forms of costs when you're loading you
know it might be you know formatting the
boxes or something like that no no no no
I'm
when you say scrolling I'm being very
precise you know why is it slow when
you're scrolling it's slow because it's
not ready to draw on screen and it's and
the cases that you often see and I hear
about are typically because it's not
even loaded from disk yet
when we go I mean this has come up
before the concept of a binary notebook
format some kind of wxf based thing does
that make any sense or is that just a
stupid idea
it's it's it would be only a small win
the and and and a lot of places where we
get some kind of win we're already
getting it in compressed data you know
there is significant overhead to pulling
down you know they say a large block of
numeric data and we get the wind because
we're already doing that in compressed
data so I mean you know we can get a
little more by going from text to binary
but it's it's just it's not enough to
make it worth it I wonder if we should I
cannot the button currently labeled icon
eyes should say I can eyes complete
expression just to sort of make it clear
you're getting however many megabytes
from the left-hand side stuck in your
notebook well Eddie ups a complete it is
just I can eyes expression communicate
the same thing I mean that size
information could also be in the first
element larger output parentheses we're
not we're dropping the words large
output okay one thing I wanted these
last two checkboxes said size limit if I
set the size limit to one gigabyte
doesn't it then automatically store the
full expression for anything less
yes because it doesn't even bring up
this stuff and so you don't actually
need that setting
what do you mean well if I said the size
limit to one gigabyte and if the output
is less than 1 gigabyte it doesn't even
bring up that short form so there's no
need for for that second checkbox
because it always thought the full
expression up to size limit
no note that's setting a different size
limit that certain limit where it will
dis it will there's a level at which
this display will come up right because
I mean I could you know I could set a
hundred thousand elements I could go and
show them all on my screen right but in
this case what I might want to do is
store those in the notebook but don't
show them on the screen so that's a
different size
right okay let me just talk about this
the thirty four megabytes thing because
it really applies to everything here
maybe we should split it at the
beginning and some with some graphic
design device look really what this is
is this is expression size because we
don't actually know what they write and
and let me point out right if if if you
set you know dollar notebook inline
storage limit to some large value then
this output size limiter would not come
up because it would have some sense of
the you know the size right there's some
estimation of what the sort of box size
will be and it knows that this has a
pretty compact boxes for example if it
hits a graphics box for a graphics 3d
box it's gonna say wow that just
basically looks like one leaf regardless
of what's inside of it right okay so um
movie on our live stream is commenting
about iOS so person just turn lazy
loading for UI skull view elements I
think we're doing that kind of thing and
happens like 30 years I think as I'm
mistaking something um yeah I think we I
mean we don't load until we need to um
okay so I propose this Billy can you try
and does it get a design you know on the
app it should presumably just stack I
mean when there isn't enough space just
stack them responsibly so to speak
mmm-hmm should you think settings should
be global I think could conceivably look
specific as well
okay I mean that that would be nice to
do if we if it's easy for us to do it
why not have a little um you know
notebook this notebook only this session
only and all always and then those
things need to go into the global
preferences yeah make sense okay I
probably should store this someplace
right we'll need some sort of a flight
button right so that it knows where do I
put this anybody at Devon do you have
any idea where this goes
I couldn't think of an obvious location
oh that looks good to me
okay we're ready to go on to the next
topic
sure okay another John topic you know
John needs to not be John needs to be
working on finishing you know that's
okay I'm completely unprepared for this
meeting so art so happy um okay right so
so Roman makes some claims about
facilities which I don't know exist so
maybe he should explain a bit more
precisely but the basic question is you
know when do we want to spin up kernels
for parallel I have them I have a more
basic question okay so when I do
parallel evaluate of you know something
like dollar machine name right by the
way I really hope that this is gonna get
modernized soon um Roman that is on the
list right to modernize that yes I mean
but are you are you in communication
with the people who are dealing with
that not at the moment
we're still working on 3.1 and this is
really not okay alright so I now have a
hundred kernels spun up right um and my
question is if I'm doing a particular
computation so I would like to partition
this so I would like to run only on some
of these kernels I'd like to run I've
got two big computations going on maybe
I've got two different master kernels
for those different computations okay
how do I do that well I mean if you have
different master kernels then you should
have two notebooks
each with a different color and each of
those kernels will launch okay how do I
tell it what to launch it's launched
from the Preferences I don't want and
the preference then then I mean you can
set up your own lists of kernels to
launch how just just assign to a
variable of your choice and so I say
kernel set 1 equals and then a list of
those kernels and Carol said 2 equals
whatever else and you just give that the
argument to launch Jones is a list of
kernel specifications to launch the
default default is dollar default
kernels also but you can just use any
list so how do I know what they're
called before they launched how do I
know what they're called
I mean look at look at your dollar
default dollar config dollar configures
kernels I think it is yes okay this
documentation is totally inadequate it
doesn't give any example of that come on
yes I mean well that's the basic
examples maybe no I mean what what's
missing here is that the different
launch was like local kernels remote
kernels lightweight wheat kernels and so
on are not documented here because they
are not in the system context
and that's why this documentation is
rather vague about how to specify
Colonels except for well but but here
you know dollar configured kernels could
absolutely be talked about here right
you could say that I mean so for example
and certainly it should be in basic
examples because how can you say launch
kernels this just shows launch kernels
open bracket right yeah you should put
that in the basic examples cuz I mean
certainly the details should talk about
God or config currency but even if I
close the kernels okay so by the way and
also this should turn into nice icons
here right the dollar configured kernels
if I close kernels right and then I say
dollar configured kernels okay I don't
understand this result at all I don't
understand what I'm seeing here I don't
understand what those things are what
are those things I mean if you look at
the input form you can against kind of
see see see it's doing well but that
thing whatever that representation is it
should be no I mean that that's how they
look but yes I mean the documentation
about the various kernel launches is
missing secure place in the package
documentation okay but but to me this
story I mean to me you should be able to
say launch kernels and then like the
name of a machine for example here right
Roman didn't we update it so that the
head of these things really is kernel
object that's for the the kernels
themselves that's for the result of
launching you see what are these things
these are some kind of this is a
configuration language so it's a
symbolic expression with head remote
machine and the first argument is the
name of the machine I think that head /
at percent is on percent 11 or no oh no
you'll be evaluate you know it's this
it's this thing okay yeah
okay so I mean the basic point here is
what you need is a symbolic
representation of the machine
yes I mean there is a symbolic
representation is just not not well
documented and you don't see and and it
has this crummy abbreviated form you see
in the middle of the screen right okay
so this is not difficult to what is
there any reason we shouldn't just clean
this up a bit
I mean it's this is all part of the the
new remote kernel launcher that I'm
working on and you all right this this
should be it should be cleaned up coming
okay but that's an active project yes
yeah 12.2 is big a vision of all of this
stuff yes I am fine fine okay all right
now let's talk about this okay so
kernels right so okay so Roman York I
guess I should have tested this
beforehand but they didn't very claim
that dollar used parallel kernels is an
existing symbol no no that's a proposal
that guy that's a proposal yes okay so
let's take an example of let me let me
say something before we dive into the
minutiae right so you know suppose
simplify wants to automatically spawn
off parallel threads well parallel
kernels not parallel threads you know
then I believe the current behavior is
if you've already launched some kernels
then some slave kernels it will use them
but if you haven't it won't and so
there's sort of two reasons for that one
is well maybe you're on a cloud server
where there are lots and lots of master
servers kernels and you don't want a
bunch of slave kernels running around
and the other is you know licensing I
mean we don't want to be eating up users
you know kernels without being very
clear about how and there's another
reason as we control it
a person who's actually doing stuff that
involves you know hundreds of kernels
and things right if I you know I can eat
my machine that I'm actually sitting at
alive by doing this exactly and I don't
necessarily want to do that yeah I mean
the short the answer is that at the
moment there is no uniform way these
Auto paralyzing functions handle in this
case and so that's what's an example of
Auto paralyzing function functions and
does Brett the first scanner to paralyze
I think it does now I I doubt that right
because the cost of transferring the
graph to another kernel would be greater
than the benefit I mean it might be
multi-threaded but it's something like
simplify with with certain piecewise
depressions but yeah and there's a
system option that controls incidentally
incidentally a comment I have this
function parallel map monitored which
should be in the function repository I'm
not sure if it's there yet um it is
super nice and we should do it by
default for parallel map have you have
you seen it or I mean I've seen it I
mean my my proposal was to make the
monitor function more useful at the
moment the monitor function just uses
some monitor or some local variables
that that may be around but any
functional programming and yeah right I
figured out how to make monitor work
that's not and so the one idea would be
to have a one argument function of
monitor data just that it has a bunch of
up values so you could say monito of
parallel map which would then do
something useful you could do monitor
off of some PD there's a servo home
which would no no just monitor of
parallel map of whatever but a single
argument form of monitor which would do
something useful with that idea
yes I think there is a good idea so if
you say /p of solve PDE it would
automatically do whatever is necessary
you don't have to worry about step
monito and stuff like that I think it's
a good idea I mean an effect we're doing
that for the machine learning functions
that automatically we have a monitoring
panel I mean the main problem is that
for parallel functions
there's no way to monitor variables on
the remote kernels that would just kill
all performance but yeah I understand
the scheduler on the master kernel has
lots of information about the progress
of the computation and we could simply
visualize that that's probably what your
current parents so just give information
about the progress of the overall
paralyzation
of the function so I mean I could
imagine a function mana toward I don't
know maybe it's the same thing as
monitor I mean right now what monitor
does right if I say monitor you know
table what the heck why am I not seeing
nothing that I probably because of
scoping I mean it's it's really not that
useful right I mean no no that should
work yes well use a small example in the
Paul's inside then you can see what's
going on and what the heck just happened
here John this is scaring me you're
gonna blame me for on kernel that's what
it was claiming and that's what it
looked like now it's a dead kernel which
apparently restarted okay so this claims
maybe it was changing too fast in the
previous example
I think so using pause or some play that
works well
okay all right so this is monitoring
with a specific monitor type there so I
guess we have to keep updating our
monetary samples because everything gets
too fast indeed that should actually be
noted for the documentation people but
some of these things that involve speed
should be changed um okay my claim is
that most interesting examples and good
code don't agree that's what I find all
the time right so I agree with you I
think the main issue is how deep does it
monitor so in other words if I've got a
big lump of code so my claim would be
actually this is a good way to think
about it monitor is like echo that what
monitor tries to do is it monitors the
outermost function that you wrap it
around which isn't actually like echo
but anyone never mind this but to be
useful each of these functions needs to
decide oh sure and so there should be a
hundred of hundred of values for monitor
exactly exactly but I mean so so this is
another possible form which is probably
obscure forget that that's a stupid form
i I think the right way to do it is as
you said one argument forms a monitor
and in which right in which it just does
the right thing for its nearest function
because the fact is there could be deep
deep functions inside X bar right and
you get in a total tangle if you're
trying to monitor but I mean you see you
could even overload monito for for
semicolon so it would then show you how
it how it progresses along the list and
it could monitor list itself and show
you how it evaluates the arguments
absolutely if you but what I'm saying
roman is that i really like this idea
but monitor should only one instance of
monitor should look only at the thing
whose head it is just is just inside it
i don't think this should be done via up
values as
Roman is suggesting because I don't
think we want to make the monitoring
function you know slow with you know
giving it hundreds or thousands of up
values you can dispatch the monitor can
just dispatch maybe these functions have
shoot register a monitor if they are if
they know if they have something useful
to do sure that's that's something that
could be you know I really like this
idea I really like this idea this is a
great idea
this is this fits into the kind of code
assistance framework as well um let's
figure out how to get this built there's
also the progress bars update that's
happening that's very related to this
indeed so who is peeing mutt let's me
okay can you do know what is it status
yeah so we've been meeting bi-weekly um
it's it's under the umbrella of LCC
julia has created a a a pretty good
looking framework so far and we're
trying to push it for 12 - I'm sure if I
can speak more to it as well
but yeah okay I think it's coming along
nicely all right so can we can we review
that in one of these meetings please and
then let's let's try and let's get a
list maybe Roman could help and get a
list of functions that are early
candidates to be monitored by monitor
okay okay and then bring that back to
this meeting alright let's talk about
using parallel kernels okay so the main
issue is if we have internal code that
contains a parallel function how does it
decide whether to run in parallel and if
it does decide to run in parallel how
many I mean what we're basically saying
here is in addition to parallel evaluate
which just says anything that's in my
launched kernels go use them right
Roman yes I mean I can imagine a case
where you might want to say well give me
three kernels you know throw three
kernels of this but don't eat my machine
alive for the sake of doing this yes
launched kernels of dunno launched ones
well if they are no no launched country
it launches those dollar configured
kernels right so it's up to you to
decide what to do what the default is
just a bunch of local kernels so that's
very cheap reasonably the main is the
main look it's all it's it's mostly not
cheap because it might eat your machine
alive right I mean if you have if you
have three different mathematical xopen
and each one of them decides to use and
pick some um number available of sub
kernels 10 OS is are quite good at time
sharing these days and they're really
not what I've noticed I mean I have the
I have the latest fanciest Mac here and
you know with the latest fanciest
operating system somewhat surprised but
the thing you know running all these
parallel kernels it succeeded in making
it so that I couldn't type which
shouldn't happen I mean we should not
allow that to happen I know I I can't
speak to how catallena scheduler works
but something can i I mean I don't have
that experience and of course of course
right now I'm fighting the fact that the
Apple Mail client is using 200% of CPU
and taking forever to do things and it's
clear from some debugging that I did
personally personally ended up doing it
that it's in the mail client but also
are you running it on you know in then X
or Wayland desktop or you SSA SS aging
into some machine because the you know
your window manager can become quite
bogged down even when you have a bunch
of low priority things running all right
any case the basic point is if we have
the possibility of parallelization in a
function should we use it
and how much of it should we do that's
the basic question I mean the main
technical problem is indeed that there
is only one set of kernels
that I understand what and you have this
weird subpar message which says you know
when I try and parallel eyes something
which is already paralyzed yes that's a
different case I mean that's just the
kernel that doesn't support parallelism
and clearly if you do this with a PDE or
something you shouldn't even bother to
tell you that but the main decision to
take in one of our functions is whether
I mean if kernels are already running
then use them it doesn't matter how many
they are right but if no kernels are
running should you I'm sorry that's not
self-evident to me that you should use
all of them I don't think it's clear you
should use all of them well I think I
think I think that's relatively
uncontroversial because if this is
something that spinning you know being
auto done by the function you're calling
you're not going to be launching
anything in those sub kernels until that
function returns and since we're not
going to have simplify you know
returning you know thinking of a single
machine place that's that you're
thinking of a single machine case look
at my case where I have a whole bunch of
different machines and we're a
completely different master kernel could
be trying to run on one of those
machines but that machine just got eaten
alive by the things I'm doing from you
know kernel a right so that means kernel
B is dead in the water on that machine
but then maybe your configuration isn't
isn't correct because then you're over
provisioning that machine no because
look well okay maybe maybe maybe maybe I
mean maybe the right answer to this is
okay so your basic claim is if the
kernels are available use them yeah my
case you'd use a hundred kernels yes I
mean if the problem is small it will not
use them anyway and if the problem is
big then you better use them right and
so I think as it I said I think that
case is probably not very problematic I
mean the bigger question is if there are
no kernels running sure they
launched default kernels or not and in
your case you certainly do not want that
because then it would take for able to
launch a hundred kernels but for some
stupid building function but some other
cases where you have just the default
local kernels configured then by all
means launch them and even after the
computation kill them and it's not that
fast to launch local kernels yeah well
it's it's really really fast I would say
yeah it's not that is it launching them
sequentially or is it launching them in
parallel I mean eventually I mean I mean
the commands are given sequentially but
they all have an ampersand at the end so
I mean it's it's just as fast as the the
different one the different link launch
commands can can work so I mean I'm just
limited by what link launch gives me
right I mean maybe we I mean maybe what
we need is sort of two sets of dollar
configured kernels there's like the the
yeah it's the I'm doing it seriously and
I mean to do it and the I might just get
used because I'm a utility Colonel I
happen to be hanging around yes I mean
that's kind of what I suggested here at
the end of that notebook that when you
have that door use parallel kernels you
can say yes use them use them only if
running don't use them and you could
maybe just also give the default
configuration you want to use for that
case the simplest case is an integer
which means that many are up to that
many local kernels and of course there
could be extended by not to just allow
any kernel configuration on the right
hand side to be used for that particular
case why not okay who are the first
clients for this what functions could
use this right so there are so you know
solve and reduce for certain types of
you know CAD or or piecewise processing
have already an algorithm to do it and
I think that the default system option
is use any existing running sub kernels
and write it was on by default and it
caused some issues so we turned it off
right so there it has right there has to
be a good way right there has to be a
way to you know say don't
although magically use things is there
any reason that for displaying in the
front end some little little flashy
thing that says you know using seven
kernels now in the in the notebook
footer for example so those functions
that do automatically paralyze would
give some feedback how are you more
interested in knowing what's going on in
the current evaluation or what is the
state of like launched kernels I think
more with kernels I you know the fact
that deep inside some function that it
didn't even write that there's some
weird you know some algebraic
decomposition happening I don't care but
I don't know something launched seven
kernels if they spend a place in the
front in your notebook well it's so the
obvious place to do this would be in the
toolbar that we've been working on you
know we you know we have a spot in the
toolbar which will give feedback about
you know kernel states or you know yeah
we just have to figure out how
graphically to integrate that
information okay well so I mean use
parallel kernels hmm
automatically use parallel kernels
really the point
you
I mean really this is dollar automatic
parallelizing
because that's what I mean but of course
that isn't really right either because I
mean every map could be paralyzed in
principle how do you decide the
parallelism error but it's really
intended for internal super functions
and so these functions should have an
option which would let everybody know
that they do support this kind of
automatic parallelization well I know
I'm you shouldn't call it automatic
paralyzation because they deserved for
for for the parallelized function
internal paralyzation or something like
that I mean
I mean some I mean at the moment is I
think it's quite a mess I mean there are
some method options that some functions
have method options that allow you to
say whether or not you want to paralyze
but we should really use internal
parallelization
yes so the analog the obvious analog to
me is what we did with auto compilation
it may be more sophisticated than that
but you know I mean we have a compiled
option that you know works in many
places yeah what's the default I don't
think we have a dollar interval for the
default so are there cases where we
think it makes sense to buy defaults
auto launched new kernels I mean is it
conceivable to consider that functions
might have like a cost function and if
the cost is high enough then we should
start watching yes I think so I mean if
it's a computation that we plainly know
is can take an hour then people are
gonna be very happy if we launch kernels
and takes point is that if you have this
dollar variable then I can set it to two
and then I will specifically love it but
John is making a different point there's
a frontier here that is there's a
certain cost I mean it's a standard so a
resource allocation issue there's a
certain cost to launching the kernels
right yes there's but if we know we're
gonna be doing a big crunchy heavy
lifting computation we should launch
them right so this is I mean the
question you could do like for example a
very quick analysis on the expression
that you pass to simplify and you know
certain markers can up the cost I mean
we could do some it's a standard machine
learning type thing estimate the cost of
simplifying this expression and I'm sure
we can quite easily get some heuristics
for doing that right so for example a
one heuristic that again I don't
remember if it's CAD or if it's solve or
both but write one heuristic is you know
the piecewise cases if they're a bunch
of orthogonal piecewise cases then it
can and that big it's less small it's
not worth the communication of that
right look to me this is a like we've
done with machine learning like we've
done a lot of other things you know
a quintessential case where we should
use heuristics possibly machine learning
generated heuristics to answer the
question what is the startup cost what
is the likely time to run and then
decide what to do by default yes I mean
it's a two-step process one is you give
these functions two permission to use
parallelism but the second one is for
each function to decide whether it's
worth to do it yes I agree with that
except I would add just because I
haven't heard this point made in the
last five minutes that there has to be a
way even if the function has the
intelligence there must be an easy way
to turn it off because say you're on the
server and you don't want sucker and
you've maximizing the number of master
kernels as opposed to the number of sub
kernels or something right yes I mean
that's what the dollar were at least
four you could turn it off right yeah
other compilation is is control das
system option which frankly I don't
think the number of people who care
about turning it on and off
you know justifies any more effort than
this this is something where I think
we'd have to have a dollar variable yes
I mean I agree I mean it makes it more
visible
I guess another question is do we well
does the current does parallel evaluate
currently do and you know is there the
infrastructure to know I guess there
must be a way to know of this is how
many sub kernel licenses are still
available for this machine yeah we can
lunge I mean that that's part of the
kernel launching right I mean that's and
it is only implemented for local kernels
it's easy to figure out what the license
limits are for remote kernels you have
to decide how many you want as a as a
specific number and so I mean if the
machine is remote I mean it would have
to ssh into it first to figure out how
many there are and so on so that's not
part of the count kernel launch about
the new one might have something like
that where you can tell tell it to
launch as many on a machine as is
possible
mm-hmm at the moment it needs to know
how many there will be beforehand
because it waits for them to come back
and it needs to know when it can stop
waiting right and this sounds like
something certainly like something where
the default auto-launch kernel it's
possibly all other launch kernels but
should be local kernels both in terms of
just how much it costs to spin them up
versus I don't think that's always true
I mean look I know you know in my little
farm of 100 kernels that I've been using
recently right when I have a big
computation to do I really want all of
them I mean makes big difference factor
of 100 is a significant perceptual
difference there's two ways to look at
this one is to say the default
configured kernels is just using local
cows so if you don't change anything it
will just use local kernels but if you
go to the trouble to define your own
dollar configure kernels to include 100
remote kernels and yes and why not use
them
but I but on the other hand I might see
a case where you would like to say okay
I have these are the kernels but I don't
want them to be spun up just because I
do some some sort of her didn't even
realize I did so I might use dollar use
internalization and set it to use only
local kernels for example so there could
be two kernel configurations one for
parallel tools and one for internal
parallelization right which if you
really wanted to you could set the
internal parallelization want to be or
100 distributed kernels but
it would be a separate you'd have to opt
into that this um okay question which
comes out of a question from Ethan on
the live stream if a kernel is not you
know if you finished using it for an
internal function but you haven't closed
it does it have a high cost to keep it
open
it's gonna use some memory some virtual
memory present yes I mean it's it's a
process that it's sleeping so it doesn't
cost anything really so in modern times
I mean I've got all kinds of junk that
sleep I mean it has a TCP connection
open it it has some memory but that
memory gets swapped out if it's not
being used I mean typically your
didn't-didn't and minds of sleeping
credulous business yeah right didn't my
thing run out of SSH slots in my
revelation then that's quite possible I
mean that I mean there are so many
configuration options there but and just
to make sure that the new kernel launch
I'm working on will make a single SSH
connection into my machine even if there
are a hundred kernels launched there
okay okay so listen with respect to this
thing um use internal parallelization
seems to me or dollar internal
parallelization maybe it's the best
thing because that's saying this is
going to specify what internal
parallelization you're going to use so
I'm saying so internal parallelization
goes to none you know yes could see none
automatic which would mean to use the
local field kernels or some lists of
kernels all a list of kernels or some or
some string name which does something
special
what awesomeness is just an integer
meaning that many local kernels right
well I think well I mean I would think
well maybe this is a different value but
I would think we need a value which says
use existing open kernels right nothing
and I was something there two cases one
is to say if none of running launch the
default kernels the other is just use
whatever is running and if nothing is
running then just do it sequentially and
there's even more stuff I mean there's
stuff like you know if you think I mean
this whole it could be some giant
Association of
options here and this is the right name
for it um and we don't think internals
going to scare people off unnecessarily
well maybe the right thing given that
it's that it's in that function itself
would be used parallelization
it's a little weird with the dollar
variable yes we could call it and maybe
we rejected this earlier but I was
thinking what's wrong with dollar Oh
dollar automatic parallelization because
because that is rejected because of
because of the fact that that there's a
much more parallelization we could do
[Music]
and I'm not sure I understand that
automatic polarization is already used
by the paralyzer functions map and
everything else we're not gonna do this
in map okay at least on that you know
for in the near future
I mean internalization isn't bad except
yeah does it scare people well also
within a particular function it's kind
of stupid to say internal
parallelization because it's the
function itself um what about just
parallelization and dollar
parallelization it's a little weird cuz
we've got parallel eyes yeah I mean
parallelization is okay but dollar
parallelization is not because that's no
longer inside that particular function
yeah Brian
is suggesting a time to live for kernels
that is if a kernel has not been used in
a while kill it off I'm not sure
necessarily that is I mean as as people
pointed out operating systems are
there's tons of stuff running yes and
what what what is a valid point is that
if that function actually launches
kernels it should probably close them
again well so long as the cost to reopen
isn't ridiculously high I mean yeah okay
but we have if you ain't if you
anticipate that then you launch them
once at the beginning and then there
will be just be used my searcher sign
by the way Mufi is pointing out the
kubernetes configuration is a useful
reference for for launching I don't
think does anybody here know about that
stuff We certainly have people who know
about that but I don't think they're in
this meeting
anybody here know about kubernetes
configuration for paralyzation roman do
you know anything about it maybe you
should ask a letter on those guys about
it um okay let's okay so on this we
don't completely know the name but we've
got a few candidates but we can start
actually thinking about doing it and
start trying to understand these cost
functions okay
all right let's let's try and tackle
this point because I think it's an
important one what on earth is this so
[Music]
this is right so the the question is
should we have you know some sort of
control equals like interface for
resource functions or should audit more
to the point which is what I support
should resource functions be in the
autocomplete in the generic autocomplete
oh well that sounds really expensive I I
don't think I would want autocomplete
you know to wait for either complete to
go to the web
like to get all the resource functions
every time I start a front-end what
we've talked about although it would be
you know some expense to build but is to
have a regularly updated pack 'lets you
know we're already asynchronously
bringing in the names for autocomplete
within the resource function wrapper and
when yeah the way the way it works is
they're cast on disk from the previous
time and when the resource when the
function resource Pacolet loads so
though it why on earth am I seeing that
in the autocomplete there why am I
seeing that that's Paco's backlit I have
nothing I don't care what it is nothing
to do with it I'm not asking you I'm
asking its exclusion right I mean we
don't really have as we've discussed
before we don't really have a good
system for maintaining or you know
dealing with all these new contexts that
pop up
right and I mean if you installed some
user so you're telling me that if if I
install some package from somebody out
in the world I shouldn't see that their
context on the doesn't want to see
contexts that are coming from internal
to the product except for the ones that
are documented and but the problem is
it's it is whack-a-mole on speed yes
well maybe it isn't no it is I didn't
install ah nothing yeah okay anyway so
yeah so basically okay so anyway the
whack-a-mole project should be continued
all right okay why isn't that all to
completing it only starts after the
kernel packets are loaded so do do some
research function evaluation wait a
moment and then do it again and it'll
auto complete the second day right the
thought of complete is created within
the kernel is okay oh right so so in the
zero state there it should say something
right right right we've plant we want to
each version have a something that's
built in using the normal autocomplete
we need to do that and so then you know
you won't see things that have been
published by Woody once at zero or two
months at zero well but hey that might
be more confusing why not just have
something that says loading autocomplete
unloaded even the first time in other
words when I first rather than but just
being dumb as a stone the first time I
do it right and bringing up nothing
bring up something that says loading
autocomplete as soon as is loaded show
the autocomplete
sure I'm sure is it useful yes I want to
see the order I don't we're getting your
attention to telling you to tell you
that we can't do anything for you yet
keep typing as if we didn't get your
attention well I might just wait for it
to load I might very well wait for it to
load because I don't know what to type
and without that I'm like what do i do
hello what's going on I think if we can
do that okay you'll know it'll be
annoying and we should only do it if we
know that the values are available or
older then you know what it's fine
use the user values one month ago it's
fine yeah okay okay so this is being
dynamically updated right right so in
one session the Downloads values and
then they become available in the next
right so assume that the cost thing is
taken care of to my mind Auto completing
you know including these things in the
autocomplete and when you select them
producing a function blob for them seems
like a good solution now there's a
separate issue of is there some other
mechanism I mean I want to the point of
another mechanism I think that mechanism
is fine
well well so here's one thing you might
want to consider for resource functions
that you've used before you might want
to show them fully in the autocomplete
while you're still typing resource
function I mean so resource function can
complete two resource function then you
type in the square bracket and such but
it could also show completions the
things you've typed in before fully yeah
why not that's a good idea
straight like this yes yes so so you
still see resource function but if if it
ranks high enough then you'd see you
know actual fully embodied resource
functions which you previously used no I
don't does a complete to the input
former to the blob and put a I think we
would both show and complete to the blob
I'm assuming the blob is visually
descriptive enough to figure out I think
it's a little confusing here we do this
and you get the name
that says you know birds say I'm just
like I typed our SEO what if I get some
you up Birds the what is I'm sorry what
does a blob look like again does a blob
not say resource functions it does not
function how where's the bird that's the
bird I finally understood about the
kakapo and the whole origin of the bird
same thing as much more taking with that
one well you know I don't think it's
that big of a deal particularly with I
think it's just a small bit of graphic
design they can fix that I mean you know
imagine resource function and then like
say the two or three entries below
resource function are just showing that
slightly indented as a little function
repository logo the next to the name
maybe yeah look I just think in the UX
it should segment off the resource
functions just so you know the reason
I'm seeing this stuff when I talked re s
is because their resource functions but
but keep in mind it will only show it to
you if you've actually typed it in
before fair enough all right probably
okay all right so under also at least
yeah I don't disagree what's this stuff
here this was just a mock-up that I
guess Richard created of a control
equals like interface for resource
function but I don't think there's any I
mean if we're happy with the current
autocomplete I don't think there's
really much point and it's also
discoverable and autocomplete which is
nice I think there is the interesting
question of whether control equals could
do this I think not all right I mean
control equals accepts arbitrary syntax
that it sends out to alpha having it you
know there's too much forever laughing
they hump reprocess that before it goes
to alpha no I'm not gonna work right
there's too much overlapping namespace
too right do you want Jacobian to go to
a resource function no we can deal with
that stuff but I I don't disagree that's
not particularly useful you acts okay
all right I think we've got a plan there
we can postpone this one to next time
it's given that we're finally over
sounds good okay thank you all very much
thanks to folks on the livestream see
you all soon